- He's the son of divorced
immigrant parents.
When he was nine, he sold
newspapers and Christmas cards
to support his family.
Today he's worth almost
three billion dollars.
He's John Paul DeJoria,
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
- Well, you get there through
one, believing in yourself.
As you know so well, when we started,
we had $700, made it day to day barely,
but we believed what we did
was the very, very best.
And it goes on the premise if you realize
that you're going to run
across a lot of rejection.
I say this time in and time out,
be prepared for the rejection.
No matter how bad it is,
don't let it overcome
you or influence you.
Keep on going towards what
you want to do no matter what,
no matter whether your
bills are paid, not paid,
someone says no a thousand times.
Again, go back to be as
enthusiastic on door number 100
as you were on door number one.
But believe in yourself,
and it's really all about knowing
you have a great service
or a great product
that will put you in the reorder business.
So you're never selling,
you're trying to get
it in someone's hands,
whether it's a service or a product,
knowing it's so darn good
that they're going to
want to order it again
or tell a friend about it to order.
And that's the real secret there.
- I quit almost twice in my life,
and when you're down and
out, it's not an easy thing.
The first time I was
homeless I was 23 years old.
Second time was when I started
John Paul Mitchell Systems
and I was in my 30s.
I started thinking how bad things are,
and oh my God, things are bad.
How do I exist in this bad situation?
I looked at "How do I get out of it?"
One time, I had no money.
I had a car that had a broken radiator,
had to keep on putting water in it,
but I would go around
collecting old soda pop bottles,
take them in, two cents for a little one,
five cents for a big one,
get some money and look for part-time jobs
no matter what they paid.
I wanted to get out of it.
I didn't want to be,
okay, I'm going to have to
stay this way for awhile,
how do I survive?
I look at how I got out of it.
And by gosh, you can get out of it.
America does work.
You just have to do something.
It's the combination of one the product,
but you could also have the
best product in the world,
but unless you tell people
about it, get them to use it,
it's just going to sit there.
So it's a combination
of a couple of things.
One, that product was exceptional.
Same with Patrón Tequilas, Paul Mitchell
or John Paul Pet, exceptional product,
but then one must do what
those that maybe aren't quite
as successful don't want
to do, whatever it takes.
Work seven days a week from
early morning to late at night.
A lot of rejection comes your way.
Overcome that rejection.
And know that what you have is so good
eventually you'll get through it.
Eventually, you get in
the reorder business.
Successful people do the
things unsuccessful people
don't want to do or have a very
difficult time doing, guys,
very difficult time.
And that is keeping yourself going
when nothing's working,
when everyone else is
saying, "No, no, no, no, no."
First thing would be in your category
make it the best you possibly can,
so when the end result is
the consumer is tasting it
is it something they want to get again.
That's number one.
Second thing is you have a story
or an excitement behind it which is true.
We did that with Patrón for example.
We had a tequila-tasting test back in 1989
at Spago's Restaurant and
we just won hands down.
So there was some validity
not just from taste
but from what was going on.
But in any product, let's
say you want to start
an envelope company, Steve,
a tequila company, anything.
You have to know yourself
that it's the best you can do.
And then you have to be
willing to tell enough people
until enough people say yes.
Once they say, you have to
put your personality into it.
Go by and thank them.
Make sure it's going well.
A lot of people just shot
something out to get,
"Can I get 1,000 customers?"
where they have the first 50 or 100
and don't pay attention to them.
You must pay attention
to your first customers
unreal attention.
It's easier to keep somebody than it is
to just try to get somebody new.
Let's do the best we
can with what we have.
See, we want to live in the now.
And usually when you're down
and out or having difficulties,
your mind is working very fast.
Not your brain, your mind
is working very fast.
And it's working an awful
lot of nows from the past.
So a lot of experiences
from the past and worries of
what may happen in the future
are going through your mind.
Well, if you can eliminate that by saying,
"Okay, there's nothing
to do about the past.
That's done.
Yesterday's newspapers.
Can't change them.
And who knows for sure what's
going to happen in the future?
Let's be here right now.
Take what resources we have
right now, act upon them,
and act towards a good future goal."
- So you are actually
going along the street
trading in, y'know, bottles
to get a nickel a piece.
- Oh, yeah, in those days,
actually it's the second time
I was homeless, okay?
But in those days,
you got two cents for a little pop bottle,
five cents for a big one.
And every grocery store
and every liquor store,
you would just bring them to
and they give you the money.
And, y'know, you do what
you have to do to exist
if times are lean.
But at least this nation
affords us that opportunity.
If you now where you're at,
well, how can I best make it to survive?
Not oh poor me.
How do I entrench myself
for longterm survival is
how to I survive right now,
get myself to the next step.
That's the attitude you have to have.
First starters, we know we
have a darn good product.
But if we take the time
with ourselves and our staff
to go there and tell them
all the ways to use it
and reassure them not
only is it a good product
but here's how you use it to
create a good salon experience
or the consumer when you take it home
to keep your hair the
same in between visits,
you fill a need in the market place.
One, there's the need, of
course, to buy a product
or another product.
But the next one is you
must constantly remind them
how to use it properly, which
makes you a little different.
Now granted, maybe there's
another one to use the same way,
but nobody told them.
We're amazed at times when people
are using our finest products
and didn't know there's
other ways to use it also.
It's through education.
You must constantly
reinforce the education
and why it's so good.
I don't care what you have in life,
no matter where you are in your life,
there always be somebody that
needs it more than you do.
So whatever you give,
as little as it might be
or whether if it's your own self,
I know in my early 20s, I
didn't have a lot of money,
but at Thanksgiving and Christmas,
I'd be in Griffith Park in
the line at the feed-in.
I'd be feeding people that
came in the lines there.
I was they're at the feed-in.
I could serve really good.
I could cut a turkey so cold, man.
I got really good at that.
I was a good server.
It made me feel good, because
I was part of giving back.
As you are a part of giving
back, it opens you up.
It opens you, the human
being, up in a huge way.
Your soul, the entity
inside of you, opens up.
It's the most amazing thing.
It's not about "poor
me, me, me, me, poor me,
"I'm going to get my little
quarter over here, poor me."
It's about "Hey, I'm going to give.
"I may not have any money,
"but I'm going to open that door for you."
You need an helping hand.
I'm going to be there for you.
I'm going to lend a helping hand.
Your whole being opens up
when things like this happen.
When we hire people at Patrón
or John Paul Mitchell Systems,
the people we hire do more than one thing.
We purposely give someone
the responsibility
of several positions.
They're paid extremely well.
We take more than good care of them,
but it gives them the
opportunity to be in something
that if times are every tough,
you don't have to eliminate anybody.
They can migrate into a variety of things,
because they're already doing it.
Now as business thinks about this
and they start hiring
people from beginning
with fewer moving parts.
We probably have one-fourth
the amount of staff
that our competitors have,
y'know, per capita and per
what we do in business.
But we hire where you
do more than one thing.
In fact, I think it's one of the things
that's going to make America great.
It made America great in the past.
It hasn't been quite as
great as it could be,
but it will be in the future.
Where people instead of
getting one job to do,
one thing all the time,
that they draw it out
because it gets so boring,
they two or three things.
All of a sudden, they're
happy what they're doing.
They're excited about it
and their day is full.
Longterm entrepreneurship
is liking what you do,
who you do it with and who you do it for.
If you're not having fun,
then you're only in business
to makes some money.
I still work.
I work every single day,
but I love what I do,
so I have fun.
So it became a lifestyle.
When you're working, it becomes work.
It's not fun.
When you're working because
part of your lifestyle,
because you like it, it's fun.
I look forward to calling on salons.
I look forward to walking in some places
and say, "Thank you for
using Paul Mitchell."
I look forward to walking
into a cocktail lounge.
"Wow, thank you for having
Patrón on the menu."
To people in the hip-hop industry,
"Thank you for singing about Patrón."
In the country-western industry,
"Thank you for doing thing."
In other words, I like it so much
that I appreciate so much also
the people that like it too.
It's a lifestyle, and it's a good one.
So if an entrepreneur can make
a lifestyle that they like
with the people they want to deal with
part of their business,
it'll be longterm and it will prosper,
because you are having fun.
And everyone wants to have fun.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Moe Modern asked me too.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
you feel most connected to,
which helped you the most.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join the discussion.
Thanks again for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.